[Musik]
wir bringen
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
fingerfood wenig x ich mach nämlich mit
etwa keine politik und vor allem mit
einer vegetarischen und einmal mit einer
füllung bis heute auch anders sein
die pinguine sind super einfach fort
bereits 50 gerade als nächste unterwegs
man kann fotos oder auch für die kleine
vertrieb und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
wie ich den hefeteig hersteller den
könnt ihr auch schon am vorabend zu
bereiten auch gerne schon befüllung und
dem klima gleich los für den pizzateig
brauch ich 225 gramm mehl jeweils einen
teelöffel zucker und trockenhefe einen
halben teelöffel preis von 125
milliliter wasser etwas pfeffer und
einflüssen esslöffel olivenöl dafür
einfach gibt es einfach alles zu tracken
gemeinsam in hörstel ich könnte aber
auch zum beispiel mit der hand kneten
und ich nehme jetzt getroffen hätte weil
ich einfach nur ein bisschen hilfe
brauche deswegen jetzt keinen hehl
würfel an brechender stimme unter
kritikern und gibt gleich auch und jetzt
mit formaten gibt auch gleich das öl mit
rein
[Musik]
der teilte gefährlich sehr schön
geschmeidig und lässt sich vom strand
und die menge erreicht übrigens auch für
eine runde pizza also könnt euch das
intuitiv vorstellen richtig schön
geschmeidig klebt nicht so schöne
handgemenge jetzt freue mich den teig zu
einer kugel streichen einfach mit etwas
öl oder zum beispiel mit mir könnt ihr
ihn bestreuen
so trocknet nicht aus dem aufgehen und
dann leg ich ihnen jetzt wird der king
abdulaziz etwa eine halbe stunde bis
runde aufgeben die sich verdoppelt hat
und in der zeit wer die chance die
füllung vorbereiten für die vegetarische
füllung traurig 150 gramm parmesan den
habe ich frei geblieben
150 g champignons castro frei esslöffel
olivenöl die gewürze salz pfeffer
thymian und will ihm eine rote friebe
eine knoblauchzehe und 100 gramm
blattspinat und für die fürther führung
brauche ich auch wundert am stand eine
entwaffnung aquarelle 100 gramm futter
hier sind ein paar oliven etwa 60 gramm
in etlichen formaten etwas mehl salz
pfeffer und basilikum und ein portmonee
mit der befüllung an ihr könnt natürlich
für die eine oder andere entscheiden
oder auch für wie ich beide machen
dafür nehme ich jetzt erst einmal die
zwiebel und knoblauchzehe und die werden
jetzt erst noch fein gehackt
[Musik]
kann ich schon mal das olivenöl in einer
pfanne geben und wer das erhitzen
[Musik]
knoblauch würfel kommen jetzt auch mit
wein und werden dabei mittlerer hitze es
war eine minute angebraten und derzeit
schon mal den spinat in feine streifen
schneiden
[Musik]
es gebe ich den spinat meter und der
fällt dann entwickeln zusammen und ich
sage ihnen solange anbraten gibt was die
kurse der flüssigkeit verdunstet
[Musik]
der spinat ist fertig natürlich jetzt
schon mal um und die champignons habe
ich auch schon mal fein gewürfelt
selbst mein herz an zu muss ich hier auf
der erweiterung wie geht es nicht warum
auch immer
und darin werde ich jetzt die
champignons noch anbraten und war
deswegen dass er auch schon wieder in
flüssigkeit verlieren und ganz so schwer
trifft auf meiner mimik salander
[Musik]
die champignons netz auch so weit sie
kommen hier mit das dürfen auch ein
bisschen abkühlen lässt die füllung
stelle ich gleich werte und für die
fotos füllung werde gibt auch schon mal
oliven und peperoni fein würfeln
[Musik]
dem opfer war ein büffel mozzarella da
ist etwas cremiger und auch intensiver
im geschmack als normaler monatelang
dazu auch ein bisschen teurer aber der
geschmack
[Musik]
die partner alle in einer schüssel ich
mich wirklich alles komplett miteinander
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt noch schwanz meter
pro pflanze auch schön cremig und dafür
verzichte ich eben auf die tomaten wurde
dann noch tomatenmark und die gewürze
und dann kann ich alles miteinander
verrühren
[Musik]
die app ist schon auffällig bei der
zweiten genauso sparsam und gewürze
zufügen und ganz schön verwirrend
[Musik]
der hefeteig wird schön aufgegangen wie
ihr sehen könnt
wichtig für ein lokal in könnte auf dem
löffel am tag vorher zu bereiten da
könnte auch nur die hälfte der hebe
nehmen reicht dann vollkommen auf den
könnt ihr dann im kühlschrank aufgehen
lassen
[Musik]
weil ich den teig auf der prämierten
arbeitsfläche schön dünn aus jetzt habe
ich vier muffin formen wie weit wird mit
wachsender einfetten
[Musik]
jetzt zum beispiel ein sprecher der
etwas größer ist als die marke v ihr
könnt aber auch im glas oder einen
teller kommt für nehmen aussprechen
jetzt guck ich mal auch von der größe
her fast wie ein kleiner nehmen und
dafür legt ihr einfach mal ein
halbfinale
[Musik]
das
ich hab ich dann fertig jetzt kommt die
füllung rein und bei der füllung vor
allem bei der vegetarischen solltet ihr
mit dem walzen aufpassen denn je nach
parmesan kann es einfach ein bisschen zu
würzig und zu salzig werden deswegen
erst reisen wenn der fahrbahn mit dabei
ist neben alf aktionäre planen kann ich
die genau gleiche menge immer entnehmen
und fülle jetzt quer hinein und streich
wieder nachgelassen
[Musik]
und so kommen die mini pizzen jetzt in
den vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad
ober unterhitze etwa 20 minuten werden
jedenfalls fast ganz unten mit reingehen
[Musik]
jetzt piccolini fertig und findige super
hübsch auf dem riesen sehr lecker und
ich habe insgesamt 32 stück rausgekommen
und ein klein wenig anzeigen bis heute
habe ich einfach nur in form rhein
gegeben
denn wer ist dann einfach so als product
officer brot und die theologie ihr könnt
ihr im prinzip wie gesagt den zweikampf
abend zu bereiten
die füllung könnt ihr auch schon
vorbereiten und dann am nächsten tag
einfach schön aufpassen
[Musik]
also wirklich lecker total würzig und
saftig und fließe piccolini oder mini
psalmen zu nennen möchte denn natürlich
pass extern warme oder auch kaltes
buffet als fingerfood mal zum mitnehmen
oder auch einfach mal frei haben und
weiter verfährt nach machen wollte man
jedoch völlig mit blog.de das jetzt noch
mal für euch
ich finde jedenfalls ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen natürlich könnt ihr euch bei
der erfüllung auch austoben sowie ihr
gerne möchte
und hier auch viel spaß und guten
appetit und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
stimme